The early 2000s saw an explosion of forensic-based
procedural crime dramas, but Bones lasted
longer than most.
The series was focused on a team of forensic
anthropologists working at the Jeffersonian
Institute who lent their skills to the FBI
to take on mysterious bodies, serial killers,
and more.
With a cast helmed by Emily Deschanel as Dr.
Temperance Brennan and David Boreanaz as FBI
Agent Seeley Booth, the show ran for 12 seasons
as the longest-running drama in Fox history.
Even if you’ve seen every episode, the show
might still have a few mysteries to offer.
Here are the things you might not know about
Bones.
High turnover at the Jeffersonian
Any show that runs for 12 seasons is going
to change up its cast a little bit, but on
Bones, characters really knew how to make
an exit.
The third season was capped off with the shocking
reveal that fan-favorite character Zack Addy
was secretly the apprentice of a cannibalistic
serial killer that Brennan and Booth had been
hunting all year.
One character’s departure from the show,
however, had more to do with real life than
the story unfolding at the Jeffersonian.
FBI psychologist Lance Sweets, played by John
Francis Daley for seven years, was killed
off in the season 10 premiere as the victim
of a conspiracy surrounding Agent Booth.
The real-life reason?
When he isn’t acting, Daley has a prolific
career as a screenwriter with writing partner
Jonathan Goldstein, producing the scripts
for plenty of movies, including Spider-Man:
Homecoming.
In 2014, they signed on to write and direct
the remake of National Lampoon's Vacation.
Daley needed four months off for the project,
and rather than sending Sweets on a long vacation,
the show’s writers decided it would be simpler
to just kill him off.
Legal trouble behind the camera
It might not be as dramatic as digging up
a dead body or tracking down a serial killer,
but Bones had its share of legal trouble behind
the scenes, too.
In 2015, executive producer Barry Josephson
sued Fox for withholding profits from a number
of people including stars Emily Deschanel
and David Boreanaz.
The suit claimed they were owed as much as
24 million dollars, accrued from airing the
show in Europe, online streaming, and product
placement deals.
Despite the suit, Fox still renewed the show
for its 11th and 12th seasons, while the case
went into arbitration.
The real forensic expert: Kathy Reichs
In the early 2000s, Fox asked writer/producer
Hart Hanson to create a forensics-based crime
show not unlike CBS's extremely popular CSI
franchise.
After meeting with producer Barry Josephson,
Hanson watched a documentary about forensic
anthropologist and crime novelist Kathy Reichs,
later saying
“What she could do with a pile of bones
was amazing."
The result was Bones, which would approach
the science-based procedural from a different
angle, with a little more humor and a lot
more skeletons.
Rather than base it on Reichs herself, though,
the show would focus on Temperance Brennan,
the forensic anthropologist from Reichs's
novels.
As for Reichs herself, she considers Bones
to be less of an adaptation and more of a
prequel, since Emily Deschanel was over a
decade younger than Brennan was in the first
book.
The Finder
Season six brought viewers an episode called
"The Finder," which introduced Geoff Stults
as Major Walter Sherman, an Iraq War veteran
whose brain injury left him with the keen
ability to see connections in things most
ordinary people could not.
Michael Clarke Duncan played Leo Knox, an
attorney turned bar owner and Walter's sidekick
in his detective duties.
“He's not crazy.
Where I come from we call Walter's gift Darna
Hula the second sight.”
Nine months after those characters were introduced
on Bones, The Finder debuted on Fox.
Unfortunately, audiences seemed to like forensic
investigations a little more than brain injuries
that give you crime-fighting super-powers.
Rather than racking up another 248-episode
run like Bones, The Finder was canceled after
only 13.
There were plans for the characters to return
on Bones, but sadly, Duncan suffered a fatal
heart attack a few months after The Finder
wrapped up, ending any further plans for a
return.
The layover that became a role
Bones enjoyed quite a few notable guest stars
over the years, including Emily Deschanel's
real-life sister Zooey Deschanel and the surprising
reveal that Angela’s dad is actually Billy
Gibbons from ZZ Top.
For British actor, writer, quiz show host
and all-around bon-vivant Stephen Fry, however,
what started out as a desire to grab lunch
with a friend on a layover wound up turning
into a recurring role on one of TV’s most
popular shows.
In 2007, Fry was on his way to New Zealand
to meet with Lord of the Rings director Peter
Jackson, and decided to break up the long
trip with a stop in Los Angeles.
Since he was in the neighborhood anyway, Fry’s
agent pitched him on doing Bones, and while
Fry had never heard of it, he mentioned it
to his friend and long-time collaborator Hugh
Laurie.
Laurie was starring in House, which was shot
on the same lot, and had good things to say
about the cast and crew of Bones.
"I said what do you know about these Bones
and he said well they're rather nice they're
just around the corner on the fox lot"
With that, Fry signed on to play Gordon Wyatt,
Booth’s psychologist.
He eventually appeared in six episodes of
the show, and presumably grabbed lunch with
Laurie a few times while he was at it.
Dodging the cancellation bullet
If you watched the last episode of Season
10 and thought that it felt an awful lot like
a series finale, there’s a reason for that.
When the episode was made, Fox executives
hadn’t yet decided to renew the show.
That put showrunner Stephen Nathan in the
position of having to switch things up.
Rather than ending the series on a cliffhanger
like he’d intended, “The Next in the Last”
had to be an episode that could work as a
satisfying ending for a long-running series,
while still leaving the door open for its
possible return if they did get picked up.
“Oh, I’m done.”
The result was an episode built around themes
of transition and reflection, where Brennan
and Booth considered moving on from their
work at the Jeffersonian.
Needless to say, they didn’t have to.
Bones was picked up for another two seasons
before finally wrapping up in 2017.
And with an episode title like “The End
in the End,” they were definitely sure they
weren’t coming back this time.
The explosive finale
After 12 years, Bones literally went out with
a bang: the Jeffersonian facilities were destroyed,
and it was an explosion that had been building
since the very first episode.
During the pilot, creator Hart Hanson had
a conversation with David Boreanaz in which
Boreanaz said “I want to blow up this lab.”
Hanson agreed that one day, he could, and
while he would later leave the show, his successor
kept his promise.
Not only did they blow up the lab, but as
the director of the final episode, Boreanaz
was the one who got to do it.